[Music]
[Applause]
zach jackson covers the browns nfl
writer for the athletic joining us on
this monday
what's the morale at camp there today
zach
well we don't see anything until uh the
afternoon dan but you have to think it's
positive i mean
this is mostly what the browns expected
i think it drug out a little longer and
we certainly have the uncertainty with
an nfl appeal
but you know from a football standpoint
this would be a win for the bronx who
never did it for this year who always
knew to some level what they were taking
on right but the nfl didn't accidentally
let it leak out back in the last six
eight weeks that they wanted an
indefinite suspension right so
for it to be six for watson side and the
nfl pa to have probably
you know chalk up the hearing as a win
and make this as a win then it's
certainly a win for the browns who think
they're pretty good and wouldn't have
done this otherwise
the reaction locally uh fans who show up
at camp with deshaun watson has been
what
um fine now there's only been one day of
open camp and it was kind of muted but
no protesters nothing i heard
you know the team has been very
coordinated but subtle and using social
media to get him out there he's only
been made available twice to reporters
both press conferences have been bad and
the second one was short right but
um
you know i don't know what the overall
negative reaction will be and certainly
some of my readers right away broke up
with the browns but i think as far as
being here and judging this morning
judging the last few weeks of brown's
fans and people invested here i think
it's been positive to desean watson and
i think it's a belief that this will
eventually go away and that people will
support him i know that's what the team
has thought going way back so i think
this was longer and more drawn out than
anyone expected but i think the browns
always were prepared to some level for
this got a question for deshaun watson
that you would want him to answer
you know that i haven't thought about
that because he hasn't really directly
answered anything and we also haven't
been able to ask you many football
questions right so
he has maintained his innocence and he's
been direct in doing that now the ruling
obviously is in conflict with that and
some of it was out there but
i just go back into this trade was made
you know on friday in mid-march the nfl
owners meetings were a couple of weeks
later
like this was construed to us
off the record and you know just in ways
things go as
as this was kind of gonna be the outcome
that desean watson made some mistakes
but didn't do
uh anything
you know really over the top and that
the team was going to swallow this
there was a sense of desperation here
obviously when you and i last talked it
was pretty clear they were going to
break up with baker mayfield you're
never getting this player if these
circumstances aren't out there right so
they took this all on and right now
it feels like a win
this is what i don't understand we're
talking to zach jackson he uh covers the
browns nfl writer for the athletic
has anybody talked about therapy for
deshaun watson because when the judge
talks about a pattern of behavior that's
egregious and the behavior was
non-violent sexual conduct with multiple
women here if you're the cleveland
browns
moving forward you feel pretty confident
that desean watson is all of a sudden
going to learn his lesson
yeah no i think there was always a level
of trust in the grounds and there had to
be
you know this isn't deciding which tight
end you're going to sign in free agency
this was taking on this player and
giving him this contract and signing up
for all this
the therapy counseling thing was
broached at the initial press conference
multiple times by people with desean and
his answer was his standard maintain the
innocence
you know and the quote that's kind of
lingered was when andrew berry was asked
if if he believed that that desean did
nothing wrong he didn't give the direct
answer but
you know i i think like i said they
always knew to some level and
all that changed was the nfl's
insistence that this was going to be
long and we'll see you know it's three
days until they can file an appeal and i
kind of see it both ways there but as of
right now the browns have to feel like
this is what they expected and they can
go forward with their long-term planning
anybody miss baker mayfield football
wise
zero
um and we've won you know the browns
will see him but
that relationship had just gone so sour
and and kind of quickly but not not
totally quickly i mean baker's
personality is baker's personality right
and when the production
didn't match and that was really twice
in three years you know after the big
rookie year
um it just it really went sideways so no
um you don't make this move after
guaranteeing baker's 19 million right
especially um if you're not totally done
but if he had got on the ir let's say
zach and not tried to play through the
injury
would he still be there as the cleveland
browns quarterback in your opinion
the fact that they got signed off from
ownership and from every level the
organization to do this indicates no to
me
i just think they didn't offer him a
contract because they didn't trust him
and i think the baker mayfield
experience was exhausting and i'm sure
the aaron rodgers experience is
exhausting for the packers but every
year he's aaron rodgers right when the
games start and that's what counts and
that's why the browns traded for deshaun
watson
uh have fun today zach and uh we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us
just a very normal day here a very
normal offseason of course zach jackson
covers uh the nfl covers the browns for
the athletic